one day James our master of microscopes
was out and about on one of his sampling
trips collecting various microbial
species from the waters around Warsaw
when he got home and began to observe
his new friends under the microscope he
saw this cool but also very very weird
green corkscrew twisting around I'm sure
of what the species was James reached
out to his mentor professor of Borgia
nazar ich her response surprised him yes
professor za Krish did know what this
species was because in 1986 she was the
one who named it microbe names are weird
and wonderful to dive into because they
can tell us so much about both the
organism and also the person who named
them for example they might tell us what
details they found most compelling about
the organism take this colony of diatoms
for example what's the first thing you
think of when you see their formation
maybe the fact that they've created some
sort of Asterix that they're almost
star-like of so it's probably not a
surprise that whoever named it went with
a stereo nella the root of which comes
from the Greek word Asti reinforced are
same for the person who named Helios OA
who seems to have been understandably
inspired by its resemblance to the Sun
then you have the less astronomical
approach like when an Italian biologist
bestowed the name tardigrade which
translates to slow stepper upon the
Magnificent but also yes slow stepping
water bear but sometimes the story
behind a microbes name is more human as
in the case of Paramecium sauna born I
named in 2007 for the late scientist dr.
Tracy M sana born who established many
of the techniques that shaped Paramecium
research for decades for a professor is
a Krish naming this species was also
more of a personal affair she founded
while traveling to visit family in
southern Poland collecting samples from
palms along the way she'd spent well
over a decade working with you glenoid
but she'd never seen a species like this
before nor could she recall reading any
descriptions that matched it so she did
what any scientist does when faced with
a mystery she dug through the literature
searching through old research papers to
see if this little green corkscrew
matched in a description of known you
glean lloyd's identifying microbes is a
complicated process we dedicated a whole
episode to how we do it and were aided
today by the massive amounts of
information readily available on the
internet but this was 1986 an era of
nascent internet precursors and of the
Iron Curtain so when professors a crush
needed to identify a you glenoid she
started with the library of papers she
already had on hand and if they didn't
contain what she was looking for she had
to hunt through their references to find
the titles of papers that might today
that would just be a cue to Google the
title but she had to send letters to
scientists and libraries around the
world to try and find someone who could
help her and then wait to hear back
hopefully with a copy of the paper this
could take months and the papers she
received were often written in a variety
of different languages but her husband's
uncle
Yanis makovski spoke nine languages six
of which he taught himself and he would
help her parse through and translate
what she read which included many of the
original descriptions of you glenoid
species jana Chmerkovskiy passed away
shortly before she found this mystery
organism and so when she was satisfied
that no
had described it before she decided to
name it for him so she called it Euglena
Chmerkovskiy onna of course you can't
just go around naming things and
deciding that's that you have to get
other scientists on board you have to
convince them that you've actually found
something that no one else has named
before so zacchara she went about
reading a paper that followed the
guidelines established by the designated
nomenclature committee these guides can
often become quite complicated because
well microbes are pretty complicated you
can't expect the business of naming them
to be straightforward for reference the
1990 revision of the international code
of nomenclature of bacteria required
four chapters to fully outline the
principles behind bacterial nomenclature
it also contains a list of 65 rules to
follow when assigning a name and 10
appendices names it turns out our
serious business but even very long and
complex naming procedures have had to
face the plot twist of molecular
techniques which have a tendency to
reveal hidden connections between
organisms that seem unrelated when
zacchara SH was naming Euglena smoke as
Kiana
she was relying on what she could see on
the bits of morphology that made it seem
more like Euglena and less like other
organisms but later analysis of the
organisms DNA would reveal what that
initial morphological categorization
couldn't that this Euglena
was actually a fake Asst a subset of you
glenoid species whose name fakest means
lentil in greek which quite nicely
describes the flattened shape that was
thought to define them until molecular
techniques showed up to reveal deeper
connections so taking into account some
additional nomenclature rules Euglena
smoke as Kiana eventually became a Vegas
smoke offski honest there are services
that let you name stars it sounds
quite enchanting but we imagine that
there must be a particular thrill in
getting to name the invisible residence
of the macrocosmos who have their own
mysterious lives and ancient histories
when we asked professors actress how it
felt to name a species she said that it
was exciting but also it was kind of a
normal thing for her she's been working
with you glenoid for over 40 years
carrying out taxonomical verifications
on the various species that exist and
she's never counted how many species
she's named or renamed over that period
well between all the people involved in
making a journey to the micro cosmos we
have currently named zero species so an
uncounted number accumulated over
decades sounds to us like a lot but it
also is fitting that the final tally is
almost a non-factor to someone who has
dedicated their professional career to
uncovering and understanding microbes in
our popular understanding of how science
gets done discoveries often sound like
singular dramatic events that trace back
through millennia of human achievement a
person scrawls a complicated equation on
a chalkboard an apple lands on someone's
head someone leaps out of a bathtub
shouting Eureka
but discoveries are also just a regular
everyday occurrence a thing happening
out in nature and in laboratories and
offices all over the place all the time
sometimes even when you're on a trip to
visit family for scientists discovery is
the job and like any job it can be both
satisfying and mundane at the same time
in fact discoveries are often undramatic
advancing our knowledge and gradual
steps like the naming of a new species
but they build on each other and build
on each other creating an ecosystem of
named ideas and organisms and mechanisms
that is always expanding and fueling the
next discovery thank you for coming on
this journey with us as we explore the
unseen world that surrounds us and thank
you especially to all of these people
now our patrons on patreon who make it
possible for us to make this show if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out Jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby